Shure:  怎么了
Shure: What's up?
Shure的女友：要去东门
Shure's GF: Going to the east gate.
Shure:  啊你不穿衣服啊
Shure: Oh, you're not wearing clothes?
Shure的女友：在上面
Shure's GF: They're upstairs.
Shure:  真抗冻
Shure: You really resist the cold.
Shure的女友：我上去弄
Shure's GF: I'll go get them.
Shure的女友：放上去
Shure's GF: Put them up.
Shure:  好
Shure: Okay.
Shure:  是的
Shure: Yes.
Shure:  嘿嘿兄弟你恶心
Shure: Haha, dude, you're gross.
Shure的女友：你真恶心啊
Shure's GF: You're really disgusting.
Shure的女友：咦，救命
Shure's GF: Ew, help!
Shure:  给实验数据提供一些正规材料
Shure: Provide some proper materials for the experiment data.
Shure的女友：救命
Shure's GF: Help!
Shure:  你要上厕所
Shure: Do you need to go to the bathroom?
Shure的女友：不是啊
Shure's GF: No.
Shure的女友：那里有电梯呀
Shure's GF: There's an elevator there.
啊?
Shure: Huh?
Shure:  哦
Shure: Oh.
Shure:  you are so clever
Shure: You are so clever.
Shure:  smart girl
Shure: Smart girl.
Shure的女友：突然想起个事来
Shure's GF: Suddenly remembered something.
Shure的女友：就很想笑
Shure's GF: Just made me want to laugh.
Shure:  什么什么
Shure: What is it?
Shure:  你说
Shure: Tell me.
Shure的女友：一会出去再问你
Shure's GF: I'll tell you later when we go out.
Shure: 好
Shure: Okay.
Shure:  什么事能乐成这德行
Shure: What could be so funny?
Shure:  你肯定没憋好屁
Shure: You probably couldn't hold in your fart.
Shure的女友：确实不是啥好
Shure's GF: It's definitely not something good.
Shure:  哈
Shure: Haha.
Shure的女友：知我啊
Shure's GF: You know me.
Shure:  你说你说
Shure: Go ahead, tell me.
Shure的女友: 我都行啊
Shure's GF: I'm okay with anything.
Shure: 啊？
Shure: Huh?
Shure的女友: 我都行
Shure's GF: I'm okay with anything.
Shure: 什么你都行？
Shure: Anything you're okay with?
Shure:  我问你要说啥
Shure: I asked what you wanted to say.
Shure的女友: 我以为你说让我说吃什么呢啊
Shure's GF: I thought you were asking about what to eat.
Shure: 嗯
Shure: Hmm.
Shure:  咋了
Shure: What's up?
Shure:  你说呀
Shure: Just say it.
Shure:  哎呦我天
Shure: Oh my gosh.
Shure的女友: 你笑
Shuna: You're laughing.
Shure:  你快说啊
Shure: Hurry up and say it.
Shure的女友：没事
Shuna: It's nothing.
Shure:  快点快点
Shure: Come on, hurry.
Shure:  不是你
Shure: Not you.
Shure的女友：耶？
Shuna: Yeah?
Shure:  哎我靠
Shure: Oh, damn.
Shure:  话都说一半了你
Shure: You only said half of it.
Shure的女友: 你就当我没说就好了
Shuna: Just pretend I didn't say anything.
Shure:  不行你快说
Shure: No, you need to say it.
Shure的女友: 不是因为我不知道要怎么问
Shuna: It's just that I don't know how to ask.
Shure:  什么东西不知道要怎么问
Shure: What is it that you don't know how to ask?
Shure的女友: 就是有一点
Shuna: It's just a bit...
Shure:  难以启齿
Shure: Hard to say?
Shure的女友: 就是就是
Shuna: Yeah, exactly.
Shure的女友: 就是突然对某件事情有一点疑问
Shuna: It's just that suddenly I have some doubts about something.
Shure的女友: 但是但是感觉这话问出来不太好
Shuna: But it feels wrong to ask.
Shure:  没事但说
Shure: It's okay, just say it.
Shure的女友:有点奇怪
Shuna: It's a bit weird.
Shure:  但但说无妨
Shure: It's fine, just say it.
Shure:  我我我能把你怎么样
Shure: What can I do to you?
Shure的女友: 你不能怎么样
Shuna: You can't do anything.
Shure的女友: 不然你会骂我
Shuna: But you'd scold me.
Shure的女友: 你会骂我神经病
Shuna: You'd call me crazy.
Shure:  我不会骂你你说吧
Shure: I won't scold you, just say it.
Shure:  你说你说
Shure: Say it, say it.
Shure的女友: 我组织一下语言
Shuna: Let me organize my thoughts.
Shure的女友: 哎呦我的妈呀
Shuna: Oh my gosh.
Shure: 能播吗？这种东西
Shure: Can this be broadcast?
Shure的女友: 不能播
Shuna: No.
Shure的女友:  哈哈哈
Shuna: Hahaha.
Shure: 那你说吧
Shure: Then just say it.
Shure的女友：这应该也能播
Shuna: This should be okay to broadcast.
Shure: 封
Shure: Censored.
Shure:  啊
Shure: Ah.
Shure: 哎呀妈
Shure: Oh my gosh.
Shure的女友:哈哈哈
Shuna: Hahaha.
Shure:  我给你脑袋拧下来
Shure的女友: 你看我还没问呢你就开始说
Shure:  不是我
Shure的女友: 快要给我脑袋拧下来
Shure:  你快说呀哎呀
Shure的女友: 不是因为你刚突然说实验数据嘛
Shure的女友: 然后我就突然想到嗯
Shure的女友: 那就是说
Shure的女友: 如果你去上厕所解决一下生理问题
Shure的女友: 嗯有什么实验数据
Shure的女友: 也是被哈哈哈
Shure:  不戴眼镜
Shure的女友: 哈哈哈
Shure:  怎么我还得盯着对着拍是吗
Shure:  哈哈哈好好好
Shure:  这实验数
Shure:  这实验数据太珍贵了
Shure:  我跟你讲，这个
Shure的女友: 这个属于事故了
Shure的女友：这不是数据了
Shure:  不
Shure: No
Shure:  这个是后续
Shure: This is the follow-up
Shure:  可能就是后面
Shure: Probably just later
Shure:  南洋理工的那个同学的作业
Shure: It's that NTU classmate's assignment
Shure:  就是就是这个
Shure: Yeah, it's this
Shure的女友：嗯，所以呢？
Lucia: Hmm, so?
Shure:  所以呢所以就那是能播的吗
Shure: So, can we even air this?
Shure:  哈哈哈什么
Shure: Haha, what
Shure:  考取南洋理工可以看
Shure: You can watch if you get into NTU
Shure:  哈哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha
Shure: 太炸裂了
Shure: It's mind-blowing
Shure:  嗨我以为什么呢
Shure: Oh, I thought it was something else
Shure:  你以为什么呢
Shure: What did you think?
Shure:  我以为有多不能播呢
Shure: I thought it was unairable
Shure:  没想到就这尺度
Shure: Didn't expect it to be this mild
Shure:  就这
Shure: Just this
Shure的女友: 哼就这什么就这你自己吃饭去吧
Lucia: Hmph, just this, go eat by yourself
Shure: 就这
Shure: Just this
Shure:  哎
Shure: Hey
Shure:  我的室友还不知道我回来今天
Shure: My roommate doesn't know I'm back today
Shure的女友: 为什么
Violet: Why?
Shure: 没告诉他们
Shure: I didn't tell them.
Shure的女友: 为什么没告诉他们
Violet: Why didn't you tell them?
Shure:  因为他们不在乎我
Shure: Because they don't care about me.
Shure:  只有你在乎我
Shure: Only you care about me.
Shure:  哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
Shure的女友：咦，咦
Shure的女友: 你也可以不告诉我
Violet: You don't have to tell me either.
Shure: 哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
Shure:  哎这两天
Shure: Lately...
Shure:  也不是这两天
Shure: Actually, not lately.
Shure:  就昨天他们到的
Shure: Just yesterday they arrived.
Shure:  然后那天跟他们唠嗑
Shure: Then that day we chatted.
Shure:  哎
Shure: Sigh.
Shure的女友：然后呢
Violet: And then?
Shure:  然后听他们讲
Shure: Then I listened to them talk.
Shure:  叫什么狗血感情史
Shure: About their ridiculous love stories.
Shure的女友: 听谁
Violet: Who did you listen to?
Shure:  就听其他的那些嘉宾
Shure: Just the other guests.
Shure:  女嘉宾们
Shure: The female guests.
Shure的女友: 这是什么相亲栏目
Violet: Is this some dating show?
Shure:  非诚勿扰
Shure: "If You Are the One."
Shure:  哈哈
Shure: Haha.
Shure的女友: 可以了可以了
Violet: That's enough, that's enough.
Shure:  就是我
Shure: So when I entered...
Shure:  我进场的时候他要放嘿嘿呦呦
Shure: They played some funny music.
Shure:  哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
Shure:  非诚勿扰不是入场的时候要放那个吗
Shure: "If You Are the One" always plays that music when guests enter, right?
Shure的女友：没看过
Violet: Never watched it.
Shure:  哇这么国民级的东西你都没看过
Shure: Wow, you haven't watched such a popular show?
Shure的女友: 可能可能
Violet: Maybe, maybe...
Shure的女友: 有的时候就是打开电视
Violet: Sometimes I just turn on the TV...
Shure的女友: 看过那么一两眼吧
Violet: And catch a glimpse or two.
Shure:  一两眼
Shure: A glimpse or two?
Shure: 好
Shure: Okay.
Shure:  啊我牙好疼
Shure: Ah, my tooth hurts.
Shure的女友: 干嘛
Violet: What happened?
Shure: 不知道啊
Shure: I don't know.
Shure的女友:该不该说坏话了
Violet: Shouldn't have talked bad about people.
Shure:  说谁坏话呀
Shure: Talked bad about who?
Shure的女友: 谁知道呢
Shure:  谁说谁坏话呀
Shure:  一看你就是
Shure的女友: 谁说谁坏话呀
Shure:  没说坏话还能用牙起瓶子呢
Shure:  是吧
Shure:  还坚硬得很
Shure的女友: 怎么了吗
Shure:  没怎么
Shure的女友:你不会吗
Shure:  我真不会
Shure的女友: 废物
Shure:  我反着我
Shure:  我得我得
Shure:  你知道把头这样180度转过来
Shure:  才能跟你的牙一样
Shure:  你知道吗
Shure的女友: 废物
Shure:  我太废物了
Shure: 啊啊啊你是能让我废物啊
Shure: Ahhh, you’re making me useless!
Shure:  这时候AI可能在想这个人类为什么哭
Shure: At this point, the AI might be wondering why this human is crying.
Shure的女友: 你嗓子怎么哑了
Shure's GF: Why is your voice hoarse?
Shure的女友: 这两天说
Shure's GF: Have you been
Shure的女友: 话说多了
Shure's GF: talking too much these days?
Shure:  谁啊我啊
Shure: Who, me?
Shure的女友：你
Shure's GF: Yes, you.
Shure:  你不
Shure: You don't
Shure的女友:感觉不到自己嗓子哑了吗
Shure's GF: feel like your voice is hoarse?
Shure:  没有吧
Shure: I don't think so.
Shure的女友：不觉得自己说话费劲了吗
Shure's GF: Don't you feel like it's hard to talk?
Shure:  那是不行了吧
Shure: Maybe it's not that bad.
Shure:  呵呵
Shure: Haha.
Shure的女友：哦，对哦，好吧
Shure's GF: Oh, right, okay.
Shure:  毕竟四四个女嘉宾呢是吧
Shure: After all, there are four female guests, right?
Shure:  哈哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.